[Musique]
le salon de Giacomo existe depuis trois
fois plus longtemps que la
circonscription de bourrassa sauvé
comme des années 50 au mur les traces du
passage de nombreux hommes et femmes
politiques depuis 60 ans
et la légende raconte qu'un passage dans
son salon a toujours été synonyme de
victoire à l'élection d'ailleurs un des
chefs est déjà venu cette année il nous
dira qui un peu plus tard
Bourassa sauvé couvre le territoire de
Montréal Nord un secteur où les
électeurs ne se font pas prier pour
identifier des enjeux on a le coût de la
vie
les Montréal nord c'était arrondissement
voit une embellie cette question de la
violence urbaine revient sans cesse aux
oreilles des candidats en campagne
merci beaucoup
la mission de madoua nikkadé perpétuer
la longue tradition de victoire des
libéraux ici moi je crois pas ça les
châteaux forts moi je pense que chaque
campagne ça se gagne sur le terrain en
répétant notamment en 7 promesses en
matière de sécurité nous au Parti
libéral du Québec ce que nous voulons
c'est investir 90 millions de dollars en
prévention pour travailler auprès des
organismes communautaires pour
travailler auprès des organismes qui ont
l'expertise ça devrait être de la
musique aux oreilles de la directrice de
la table de quartier mais des années
d'inaction politique ou d'action
sporadiques la rente prudente
on a eu la crise après les émeutes de à
la suite du décès de Freddy Villa Nova
il y a eu aussi une crise des demandeurs
d'asile en 2016-2017 ensuite il y a eu
la crise de la covid et puis tout ça
était ponctué par des crises de violence
urbaines et on travaille toujours dans
l'urgence et ça pendant 20 ans ça n'a
pas transformé le quartier avec de très
nombreux partenaires elle vient
d'élaborer le premier plan de
développement social à mettre entre les
mains de toutes celles et ceux qui
aspirent à les représenter on connaît
les enjeux on connaît les solutions mais
si après ça on passe pas à l'action
c'est sûr que les citoyens sont
sceptiques c'est sur les plus désabusés
que contre la candidate conservatrice
dans le secteur je crois que pour être
libre chez eux ils vont aller voter et
c'est moi c'est cette population là que
je dois aussi aller chercher ceux qui ne
votent pas les nouveaux les plus jeunes
et il y a un terreau fertile pour ce
genre de profil des jeunes
pour reprendre la liberté du Québec
ou d'autres comme cette imprimeur qui
avait une sensibilité plus libérale
avant moi j'ai penché de la balance avec
le parti qui soutient les entrepreneurs
de Montréal Nord justement et c'est le
cas du Parti conservateur qui a fait
imprimer chez lui son matériel de
campagne d'autres électeurs sont à
quitter le navire libéral pour un
horizon Bleu Poudre moi je vote les
libéraux généralement donc je suis un
immigrant on est très bien vu par les
libéraux mais je trouve que le premier
ministre c'est un monsieur CCR il se
pourrait que je change mon physique
d'épaule la prochaine fois la candidate
de la CAC c'est qu'elle peut capitaliser
sur les déçus elle compte le faire en
appuyant en particulier sur le bouton
santé moi ce qui me tient à cœur je veux
dire je suis médecin de formation c'est
plutôt le côté médical et dans borasa
sauvé c'est là où on retrouve le plus de
gens qui n'ont pas de médecin de famille
réplique de la candidate libérale
à doubler dans les quatre dernières
années dans cette circonscription ou
après les Haïtiens la deuxième
population immigrante vient du Maghreb
Québec solidaire espère faire des gains
auprès des critiques de la loi 21 sur
les signes religieux de son côté le
Parti québécois nourrit des espoirs
mesurés lui qui figure en 5e position
dans les intentions de vote à propos de
l'issue du vote Giacomo sera-t-il
l'oracle de cette élection celui qui est
venu s'asseoir sur son fauteuil c'est
Éric zohème
mais cette fois le barbier c'est bien
gardé de prophétiser sa victoire ici
Mathieu pros Radio-Canada Montréal